سحابه الدخان تضيق الخناقه على طهران ومدن
ايرانيه اخرى
كمؤشرات التلوث بلغت معدلات غير مسبوقه
وخطيره لم تترك للمواطن كثيرا من الخيارات
للتعامل معها
[موسيقى]
الا عند الحاجه وادعوا الحكومه للبحث عن
حل جذري
تصعب رؤيه معالم طهران مع وجود نحو 8
ملايين سياره ربوعها بات قديما وجميعها
يعمل بوقود لا يتطابق غالبا مع المعايير
الدوليه
ومع نقص الغاز الناتج عن زياده الاستهلاك
الشفوي تلجا المصانع الى العمل بماده
المازوت ما يعني انبعاث غازات سامه على
مدار اليوم ظاهره تودي سنويا بحياه نحو
20,000 مواطن يتجلى ذلك في زياده اعداد
مراجع المشاكل لمشكله في التنفس في الهواء
النقي بشكل كامل لم يدخل رئاسه سكان طهران
منذ سنوات
هذا التلوث خطير جدا على مرضى القلب
والتنفس الغازات السامه المنتشره في
الهواء ذات اثر سرطانيه
النقيا لذا ننصح المواطنين بعدم الخروج من
منازلهم الى للضروره
لم تنجح السلطات للسنوات في حل المشكله
اكتفت بتعطيل المدارس والجامعات الايام
بدلا من اغلاق المصانع ولو بشكل مؤقت ربما
فضلت حتى الان تحمل خسائر اقتصاديه
الناجمه عن التلوث تقدر بنحو 8 ملايين
دولار سنويا على تحمل عبء مكافحه الظاهره
وتكلفتها الاقل وحتى ذلك الحين يوصل
الايرانيون قتل هواء عاصمتهم
فيقتل منهم يوميا
يدعو الخبراء الى تجديد اسطول النقل العام
وابعاد المصانع عن المدينه
وتحذيراتهم تتجاوز المخاطر الصحيه
والبيئيه فهذا القاتل الصامت قد يدفع سكان
العاصمه يوما الى هجرتها عمر هواش الجزيره
طيران